welcome to the presentation on 45-45-90
triangles let me write that down
oh I'll come to pity so there you go
45-45-90 triangles or we could say
45-45-90 right triangles but that might
be redundant because we know any angle
that has a ninety degree measure in it
is a right triangle and as you can
imagine the 45-45-90 these are actually
the degrees of the angles of the
triangle so why are these triangles
special well if you saw the last
presentation I gave you a little theorem
that told you that if two of a base
angles of a triangle are equal and I
guess only a base angle if you draw it
like this you could draw it like this in
which cases maybe not so obviously a
base angle but it would still be true if
these two angles are equal then the size
that they don't share so this side on
this side in this example or this side
and this side in this example that the
two sides are going to be equal so
what's interesting about a 45-45-90
triangle is that it is a right triangle
that has this property and how do we
know that it's the only right triangle
that has this property well you could
imagine a world where I told you that
well this is a right triangle
this is 90 degrees so this is the
hypotenuse right so sides opposite the
90 degree angle and if I were to tell
you that these two angles are equal to
each other what do those two angles have
to be well if we call these two angles X
we know that the angles in a triangle
add up to 180 so we'd say X plus X plus
this is 90 plus 90 is equal to 180 or 2x
plus 90 is equal to 180 or 2x is equal
to 90 or X is equal to 45 degrees so the
only right triangle in which case in
which the other two angles are equal is
a 45 45
90 triangle so what's interesting about
a 45-45-90 triangle well other than what
I just told you let me I want to be
redrawn I'll be draw it like this so we
already know that this is 90 degrees
this is 45 degrees this is 45 degrees
and we based on what I had just told you
we also know that the sides that the 45
degree angles don't share are equal so
this side is equal to this side and if
we're viewing it from a Pythagorean
theorem point of view this tells us that
the two sides that are not the
hypotenuse are equal so this is a
hypotenuse so let's call this side a
decide B so we know the from the
Pythagorean theorem let's say about
hypotenuse is equal to C the Pythagorean
theorem tells us that a squared plus B
squared is equal to C squared right
excuse me well we know that a equals B
because this is a 45-45-90 triangle so
we could substitute a for b or b for a
but let's just substitute b for a so we
could say b squared plus b squared is
equal to C squared or 2b squared is
equal to C squared or B squared is equal
to C squared over 2 or B is equal to the
square root of C squared over 2 which is
equal to C because we just take the
square root of the numerator and the
square root of the denominator C over
the square root of 2 and actually even
though this is a topic on this this is a
presentation on triangles I'm going to
give you a little bit of extra
information on something called
rationalizing denominators so this is
perfectly correct we just derived that B
and we also know that a equals B but
B is equal to C divided by the square
root of 2 it turns out that in most of
mathematics and I never understood quite
exactly why this was the case people
don't like square root of two's in the
denominator or in general they don't
like irrational numbers in the
denominator irrational numbers are
numbers that you know they have decimal
places that never repeat never end so
the way that they get rid of irrational
numbers and the denominators that you
call it you do something called
rationalizing the denominator in the way
you rationalize the denominator let's
take our example right now if we had C
over the square root of 2 we just
multiply both the numerator and the
denominator but the same number right
because you multiply something numerator
and the denominator by the same number
that's just like multiplying it by 1 and
square root of 2 over square root of 2
is 1 and as you see we reason why we're
doing this is because square root of 2
times square root of 2 what's the square
root of 2 times square root of 2 right
it's 2 right
we just said I mean something times
something is 2 well the square root of 2
times square 2 that's going to be 2 and
then the numerator is C times the square
root of 2 so notice C times the square
root of 2 over 2 is the same thing as C
over the square root of 2 and this is
important to realize because sometimes
while you're taking a standardized test
or you're doing a test in class you
might get an answer that looks like this
has a square root of 2 or maybe even a
square root of 3 or squared whatever in
the denominator and you might not see
your answers if it's a multiple choice
question what you need to do in that
case is rationalize the denominator so
multiply the numerator the denominator
by square root of 2 and you'll get you
know square root of 2 over 2
but anyway back to the problem so what
did we learn this is equal to B right so
it turns out that B is equal to C times
the square root of 2 over 2 so let me
write that so we know that a equals B
right and that equals the square root of
2 over 2 times C now you might want to
memorize this although you can always
derive it if you use the Pythagorean
theorem and remember that the size that
aren't the hypotenuse at a 45-45-90
triangle are equal to each other
but this is very good to know because if
you're say you're taking the SAT and you
just solve a problem really fast and if
you have this memorized you and someone
gives you the hypotenuse you can figure
out one of the sides very fast or
someone gives you one of the sides you
can figure out the hypotenuse very fast
let's try that out so I'm going to erase
everything so we learned just now that a
is equal to B is equal to the square
root of 2 over 2 times C so if I were to
give you a right triangle and I were to
tell you that this angle is 90 and this
angle is 45 and that this side is let's
say the side is 8 I want to figure out
what this side is well first of all
let's figure out what size the
hypotenuse well the hypotenuse is the
side opposite the right angle so we're
trying to actually figure out the
hypotenuse let's call the hypotenuse C
and we also this is a 45-45-90 triangle
right because this angle is 45 so this
one also has to be 45 because 45 plus 90
plus 90 is equal to 180 so this is a
45-45-90 triangle and we know one of the
sides the side could be a or b we know
that eight is equal to the square root
of two over two times C C is what we're
trying to figure out so if we multiply
both sides of this equation by two times
the square root of two all right I'm
just multiplying it by the inverse of
the coefficient on C because then the
square root of two cancels out that
square root of 2 this 2 cancels out with
this 2 we get 2 times 8 16 over the
square root of 2 equals C which would be
correct but as I just showed you people
don't like having radicals in the
denominator so we could just say C is
equal to 16 over the square root of 2
times the square root of 2 over the
square root of 2 so this equals 6
square roots of 2 over 2 which is the
same thing as 8 square roots of 2 so C
in this example is 8 square roots of 2
and we also know since this is a
45-45-90 triangle that this side is 8
hope that makes sense
in the next presentation I'm going to
show you a different type of triangle
actually I might even start off with a
couple of more examples of this because
I feel I might have rushed it a bit
anyway
I'll see you soon in the next
presentation